the British have a lot of institutions
and one by one they're shipping them
over here first there was a Queen Mary
then the London Bridge and now they've
sent us another of their national
treasures
to present the next award here is one of
England's most distinguished actresses
Dane Edith Evans
Jamie does welcome to Hollywood
thank you mister yes I think you can
take me yet around the time well I'd be
honored to take you around the time what
would you like to see the Mark Taper
Forum the Huntington museum or the Music
Center
well how does the pink pussycat grab you
well my wheels are outside and right
after this gig I'll snatch my love beads
and we'll groove honey when I just went
with it to present the award for the
best achievement in film editing now I
will eat your old school children are
making their own films everyone is aware
what an exacting our teachers to splice
together bits of celluloid into a
continuity and the nominees in this
category are Frank P Keller for Beach
read my current new channel for the
Dirty Dozen
Samuel EB clay and Marjorie Fowler for
dr. Doolittle Robert C Jones for guess
who's coming to dinner and he'll Ashby
for in the heat of the night
the winner is Hal Ashby
to repeat the words of a very dear
friend of mine last year when he picked
up his Oscar I only hope that we can use
all of our talents and creativity
towards peace love thank you